the stench of death
and the sound of grief
the mass Imperial for a dozen victims of
a landslide in the village of kusho in
the southern Philippines
this is Ground Zero of the disaster left
by tropical storm Nagi
the trauma is still visible on John
masuka's face she recalls very vividly
what happened when the storm caused a
landslide
I got stuck in barbed wires and that's
when I accidentally let go of my baby
I wasn't able to save her I tried I
tried to entangle myself in the wire so
I could stretch out my hand to catch her
but I wasn't able to
her husband and six-year-old boy also
survived but many relatives did not
three years ago residents here were
relocated from the original Coastal
settlement to keep them safe from Storm
surges they couldn't imagine a landslide
would kill their loved ones now they
wonder where they can be safe Jerry
Anton is Jon's cousin he was a nearby
cotabato City when the landslide
happened but he was one of the few
members of their family who laid their
loved ones to rest
it hurts so much it was like sleeping
and then waking up to a nightmare we
don't know how we'll be able to start
over
on Tuesday president Ferdinand Marcos
visited survivors who were staying
temporarily in an elementary school he
assured them his government is willing
to help
I already extracted social welfare
secretary Edwin tulfo to hand out a
hundred or two hundred dollars to each
of you so you can buy construction
materials to rebuild your homes
however is where to build those homes
both survivors and local officials agree
it would be unbearable to have to relive
this trauma born below Al Jazeera
cushion Southern Philippines